c'est pas
hier soir avec ollanta une semaine sans
koh lanta et les audiences force est de
constater les audiences ont baissé près
d'un million de téléspectateurs en moins
par rapport à il ya quinze jours du coup
on s'est posé la question est ce que tf1
serait pas en train de saborder
carrément le point le plus fort de nos
la grille et de la chaîne c'est vrai que
honnêtement c'est c'est quand on prend
l'ensemble des saisons balle à sa baisse
alors que normalement guillaume le
programme cartonne allait bien sûr de
cinq cartons d'habitude ils sont entre 5
et 6 millions vendredi là ils sont sous
la barre symbolique des 5 millions ils
sont à quatre millions trois cent mille
téléspectateurs et on voit bien que le
vendredi voilà il prenait ses 2 millions
de téléspectateurs là c'est un choix
terrible qui est très critiquée dans le
petit milieu des médias mais aussi chez
les téléspectateurs aient eu des
milliers de tweets hier soir je les ai
sortis de gens qui se plaignent de la
diffusion mardi c'est terrible ce un
choix catastrophique de la part des gens
il y avait un embarras en fin d'émission
il y avait le concert hommage direct qui
lui avait monde j'ai aimé la fois la
ferme ça bon score
peut pas agir comme me suis tourné vers
lui on peut penser que effectivement le
concept de johnny en a pris un peu je
pense pas que ça joue ça je pense que ça
joue qu'à la marge mais effectivement
quand on regarde psychologiquement le
téléspectateur même si c'est la deuxième
fois que c'est le mardi le
téléspectateur et préparés à le voir le
vendredi et on constate que 63% des 4/14
ans donc des très jeunes regardent quand
c'est le vendredi et là du fait qui a
classé ils n'étaient plus que 5 et 106
que 50 % hier soir il n'y a pas que ça
gal jour de diffusion mais aussi le
contenu de l'émission et le contenu de
l'émission nous avait promis des all
stars incroyable et c'est ça fait 20 ans
et ce n'est pas incroyable dit si tu
penses que tf1 est en train de cesser sa
bonhomie aborder la barre et oui c'est
trop c'est trop parce que ces all stars
on les voit tout le temps hier elle les
femmes disaient c'est ma quatrième
édition ma quatrième participation
il ne se passe rien sa part lee le débat
ni artificiel il ne se passe rien alors
cette saison il y avait il y avait en
fait deux clans les hommes et les femmes
oui la réunification et il ya combat je
crois qu'on balle était bien avec les
filles franchement été bien est clair
que ça fait limite peur ou d'autres
filles regardez c'est un mythe une
mixité des équipes pour koné la borne
on notera t j pour démonter tous les
mecs on pourrait les utiliser à notre
avantage autre avantage du monde de nos
vallées jette aussi un sentiment
vraiment construire c'est dire comme des
soeurs et là j'ai envie de mettre les
femmes à l'honneur on se retrouvera la
fin du jeu on se demande maintenant soit
tu marches avec nos sentiments avec nous
parce que nous on va élaborer un plan
maintenant pendant l'élaboration ce plan
tu pourras te situes marche pas et qu'on
ne pourra pas rester en fait je pourrais
aussi tu veux retourner à la forêt parce
que tout est à faire nous on fera notre
plan en fait j'ai un peu pas le choix
c'est un peu une menace en gros caillou
fait franchement c'est un nous fait un
ultimatum
cette fois de mettre les garçons et les
filles séparément au début d'émission
non il y en a plein qui clôt sexisme
n'en est clairement ils sont en train de
saborder la marque alors est-ce qu'ils
en ont marre de koh lanta je sais pas
est ce que c'est parce que vous savez
que le koh lanta est produit par le
groupe banijay dont cyril fait partie et
ce qu'ils veulent pénaliser peut-être
produit indirectement mais clairement on
a l'impression qu'ils veulent saborder
l'émission cc c'est un échec total de
mettre le mardi c'est ça c'est ça vous
pensez que tf1 un peu en bisbille je
pose des questions je pensais à mes jeux
il faudrait demander pourquoi
ça voudrait dire que tf1 en fait se tire
une balle dans le pied j'ai pas d'autre
explication que ça il mettrait des
bâtons dans les roues avant koh-lanta
koh lanta était le vendredi ils l'ont
remplacé par des divertissements
extrêmement faible et le mardi soir ils
avaient des fictions qui était très
puissante et il m koh lanta qui marchent
pas moins alors quand même ce boys et
danse avec les stars mais aussi à la
place donc ils ont deux grosses marques
qui arrive le vendredi saint jory
alternait mai koh lanta c'est une saison
pleine avec moi ma nature c'est vrai que
bing nettement une baisse de 1 million
comment lancer le programme le 25 août
mais 25 - d'audience il ya moins de gens
devant la télévision ils voient ça très
fort 5 millions 7 hier soir à vue
pendant tous ces noms il ya la majorité
des parents mais que les enfants cc je
pense que c'est vraiment ça le truc le
vent voilà le mardi les enfants sont au
lit à 21h il reste pas devant la télé
jusqu'à 23 heures les enfants quand tu
en as classe le lendemain je pense que
c'est vraiment le facteur déterminant
sur n'y a pas trop avec le contenu la
preuve qui a clairement un rejet de
cette programmation de mardi c'est que
l'émission n'a jamais autant marcher en
replay dont ils font énormément de gens
replay mais le soir même c'est pourtant
mon avis le vrai c'est danse avec les
stars ça existait avant déjà il
alternait comme les éclairages de
guillaume ils sont bien de savoir que
c'est le même groupe que moi je
comprenais pas votre question est
pourquoi oui pourquoi ils sabordera leur
programme parce que moi ce qui m'avait
choqué c'est pas johnny hallyday moi qui
m'a dérangé c'est le mardi qu est ce qu
a eue mardi maintenant pas comment ma
doute le mardi maintenant il ya la ligue
des champions qui est revenu sur canal +
lat à lille qui a joui à savoir psg qui
va joueurs mardi si c'est un grand match
du psg le mardi ils vont se dire encore
une autre ville dans le piège qu'il faut
penser aussi que le pôle hard à 3 pour
toi le polar de l'a3 et pour ceux pour
d'autres la ligue des champions
cette année il yal'idée bannir oui enfin
seule différence contre quand on est
banni on a moins manger l'afrique c'est
vraiment deux salles deux ambiances
rendre le camp de base et ceux qui sont
pas libres on parle de bouffe regard des
nouvelles aventures qui déplaît lanta
naïve offert un festin on a un poisson
chat cancer c'est indescriptible hugo et
karima n'ont pas le choix de tout manger
une fois ils n'ont rien eu les boules de
chair comme ça c'est trop bon ag fin
voilà beaucoup de magasins plaisir de
dingue un peu mal au coeur cette fois
des poissons vraiment près deux mois et
de 0 h pour aller manger du thon
j'ai été très bonne un joli col mais le
plus difficile et je le savais pour moi
dans tiercé a faim on ne peut pas parler
tellement c'était ce qui est bon
c'est
excellent derrière la succession
de s'animer caniche on est éliminé on se
trouve sur une île de banny on a une
seconde sonde pour éventuellement
réintégrer ça fait beaucoup beaucoup oui
oui c'est ça marche pas parce que du
coup il n'y a pas d'enjeu enfin il
n'avait pas vraiment éliminer vous avez
le sens de vous rattraper donc ils font
planer un suspense mais c'est artificiel
et du coup les gens n'accroche pas quoi
c'est j'arrive vraiment qui reste et qui
part et ça c'est troublant c'est déjà
fait mais il y avait déjà avalé un seul
candidat c'est déjà arrivé mais las
illas et des semaines successives où ils
se battent les uns avec les autres
samarraï avait il y avait cindy et
patrick qui fait sur les débats ni et
bien que patrick il et il est
extrêmement extrêmement confiant il
devrait pas en fait à regarder c'est une
nouvelle aventure qui démarre pour moi
mais là j'ai hâte d'en découdre et que
je gagne voilà que je les écrase notre
aventure dans ce koh lanta la légende
cindy est terminée au revoir à voir
denis par munch arnaud démare koh lanta
j'ai une revanche à prendre
je promets que je peux arriver à
retourner dans cette aventure patrick
votre aventure sur ce koh lanta la
légende est terminée au revoir patrick
non retenu au revoir tout le monde mon
carré bras d'hugo
strange et vous remercie
donc le kitsch ou est ce que tu es un
sabord de la marque est ce qu'il n'ya
pas une usure du probable aussi ça fait
vingt ans quand même ça fait vingt ans
que ça existe pour ça l'est
effectivement c'est quand même des têtes
d'affiché canton même kolontar on
retrouve l'été aura les clones et mr et
oh ça c'est sûr que ça fait de
l'audience après ce qu'on les a pas trop
vus en effet c'est maintenant ça
cartonne toujours
énorme que ça cartonne en replay donc on
peut quand c'était l'autre jour donc
c'est pas une question ni les
cartonnettes toujours avant la question
c'est pourquoi changer de jour est ce
que tout ça gagne harb a plombé le
groupe banijay en disant bas nous on
s'en fout on laisse passer et on va
plomber le groupe banijay qu'on nous
garons garde koh lanta le changer de
jour pour le mettre à mardin c'est
incompréhensible pour toujours plein de
gens maintenant laisser regarder oui
c'est ça parce qu'il ya une vraie
dégringolade des chiffres on l'a bien vu
un toute façon d'audience à lui et ce
régulièrement pourtant tous ces
personnages qui jouent là dedans parce
que c'est un jeu ils sont emblématiques
les gens devraient être adhérer être
sympa avec eux c'est à dire avoir de
l'affection que ces états mais le vrai
truc effectivement c'est la date c'est
le mardi c'est pas possible parce que
c'est un programme qui était destiné
également aux enfants parce que c'est
des il ya une espèce davanture les
enfants raid aventure de deux palmiers
de soleil
voir des gens de télévision sur des pros
qu'est ce qui leur passe par la tête
pour décidé d'enlever un programme qui
depuis 20 ans et le vendredi saint fons
que service qui fonctionne très bien
quelle que soit la concurrence c'est
ingérable savary à quoi l'être 238 prêt
pour le mettre à mardi où il est le plus
forte concurrence patrick c'est
une des explications c'est que tf1
faisait beaucoup de séries américaines
notamment le mardi soir et que pendant
le vide donc en 2019 2020 il y avait
beaucoup tournage ont été annulés donc
là en 2021 ils ont plus de série à
mettre donc ils mettent koh-lanta mais
ils auraient dû mettre d'autres formats
comme gameloft annonce qui met le
vendredi qui ne marche pas donc en fait
c'est un sacrifice voila voila c'est
l'excusé officielle mais même ça ne
justifie pas parce que koh lanta c'est
leur marque forte c'est la marque avec
laquelle ils font 6 millions 6 millions
500 mille téléspectateurs ils font plus
ces audiences a donc quatre millions
c'est très bien pour tf1 aujourd'hui
mais pourquoi ici ils sabords il savoir
normal qu'ils marchent alors qu'ils
auraient pu mettre d'autres formats plus
faible mais il reste quand même en tête
avant c'était la vancelle ils peuvent ce
qu'était antenne en même temps avec koh
lanta on y voit les laisserai pas fiasco
non plus mais quand vous perdez 1
millions en trois semaines alors que
c'est là où est censé être le plus fort
oui ya même quelqu'un qui peut se poser
robes avancé dans l'émission avec 7 a
besoin d'éducation et laurent découvre
ces nouvelles petites copines et le
dessin avis un très tranché regardez
yannick lange a
observé des nouveaux arrivants du
nouveau colloque à ça fait plaisir de
voir des filles maison tu vas aller ce
qui arrive qui marche ça sent goldorak
tu vois qui marche comme ça et puis s'il
fait toujours un peu la gueule du voile
un peu chelou est au final très très
sympa alix très très sympa je savais que
clémentine était un peu ouvre donc ça
confirme qu'elle était brun est toujours
là est vraiment un plot jade aussi de
loin est fait un peu flipper un patron
faire super sérieuse et alexandra aussi
un peu choix peu à peu perché
l'impression un peu à l'ouest un peu
comme moi mais mes encore plus percée
que je te ce que je pensais plus
alors vous allez au combat il ya un cri
de guerre chaque année c'est un oui
généralement c'est un grand moment et là
les rouges n'avaient pas encore leur cri
de guerre ils ont donc que j'étais ils
ont bien réfléchi et ils ont trouvé un
on va les cohérences orné d il est
magnifique
ça vient ça comme ça c'est marrant
j'ai dit ça comme ça pour rigoler oui il
après ça au sérieux maintenant ils vont
faire ça comme crimes de guerre c'est
n'importe quoi
maintenant
je dis ça comme ça pour rigoler c'est
n'importe quoi
alors dans les dents les problèmes qu'on
pourrait évoquer il ya les fameux
changement de mécanique oui c'est vrai
que chaque année il ya des petites ouïes
améliorations pour essayer de faire
évoluer la mécanique est là généralement
quand denis brogniart explique les
choses c'est encore pire que moi on ne
comprend rien
une fois n'est pas coutume regardez bien
si quelqu'un comprend ce qu'il est en
train d'expliquer bah dites moi parce
que je n'ai bien sûr rien compris seize
au total après deux obstacles vous allez
découvrir 14 torche
une nominatives pour chacun des
aventuriers qui sont ici vous allez
choisir la torche d'une femme qui
partira à son tour pour aller récupérer
la torche d'un homme dès l'instant que
tout les torches ont été récupérés dans
chaque équipe alors partez avec votre
portefeuille vous effacer tous les
obstacles efron ce jeu de confort il
commence maintenant
claude
c'est compliqué j'ai aucune idée de ce
que je vais faire des
[Applaudissements]
amis mais un raid aventure qui a marqué
l'histoire ces caches island donc c'est
vrai que quand on doit énoncer les
règles parce que en fait les créateurs
dans leur petit coin ils font leur
machin l'optique rabary long mais quand
ils vous donnent la fiche dire que vous
êtes là et quand je pense que je dise ça
ça va être très compliqué et je mets la
base de données c'est très très
difficile de venir expliquer clairement
autant faire un magnéto c'est plus ça
oui j'ai il a quelques secondes
seulement donc il le fait vite mais
parfois c'est tellement incompréhensible
que des techniciens ou des gens de la
production vm ré expliquer aux candidats
avant qu'ils se lancent comment ça
fonctionne un candidat m'a expliqué sa
heureusement qu'on aurait explique après
sinon ça aurait même pas encourir où
aller que faire des heureux quel est
l'intérêt vous pensez de modifier les
règles sur un jeu qui fonctionne très
bien parce qu'ils veulent pas lasser
mais pour moi c'est une erreur et
mécanique qui troublent et qui sont
souvent contre l'esprit du jeu et
j'arrive pas à apercevoir pourquoi la
production change en permanence les
règles mal moi c'est mauvais denis dit
systématiquement alors après à tort ou à
raison et qui change par petites touches
parce qu'effectivement ils sont obligés
sinon les gens décrocherait mais il
arrive qu'on se plaindraient tout le
pain je dire d'autre se plaindraient si
c'était les règles mêmes règles depuis
20 ans dirais même temps ils n'évoluent
pas ça change pas on va parler de fort
boyard fort boyard les règles
fondamentales man and on passerait de
plus 20 ans les cellules ont changé les
joueurs ont évolué les la volcanique à
la pas beaucoup bougé globalement
c'était toujours la même chose et le jeu
fonctionne très bien mais il ya une
nouvelle épreuve donc forcément de
nouvelles règles c'est une règle d'une
épreuve c'est pas l'épreuve la mécanique
de lutte d'ensemble de l'émission oui
c'est alors pour le voit ce qu'il était
il ya une usure c'est vrai j'avais une
petite l'usure est gay sur l'usure
honnête oui nous aurons guillaume a tout
à fait raison il ya le déficit de séries
américaines celles qu'ils ont un stock
ne marche pas ils le savent et donc
effectuerez un entonnoir de programmes
qui arrivant dans le danse avec les
stars et the voice qui chante il ya un
jour qui chantent ils risquent de
déstabiliser aussi des doutes on va
rester dans les règles justement là
cette année il y avait le totem
d'immunité et là il ya le super totale
d'immunité est super total de la
supériorité de lui même annulé
l'ensemble du trm d'avant regardez vous
allez disputer dans un instant votre
première épreuve d'immunité collective
regardez avec quoi va repartir l'équipe
gagnante ce totem
[Musique]
c'est évidemment du mal
après les terribles sur la console aux
bonnets dd 2 heures 10 points au final
optionnel est ce que les missions qui
vous a séduit oui ou non on commence
avec bernard non non non mais moi ça m'a
jamais embêté oui moi je veux bien
scénarisé un problème de connexion pour
le bras c'était c'était pour la salle
aux questions non non non ça ne séduit
pas du tout moi je regarde pas toutes
façons avec lui hier soir j'étais au
concert de johnny donc je n'ai rien pour
être agréé toutes les coulisses bon bah
tout savoir oui oui tout ça va bientôt
savoir la police et bien moi ça me
séduit pourquoi parce que c'est une
émission que je n'ai quasiment jamais
regardé pour quelle raison justement
elle est le vendredi soir et le vendredi
soir parfois j'ai d'autres choses à
faire vous êtes en flec vous le vendredi
soir aussi ah oui avec l été avec roger
ebert avec 21 mai à bas les bips ait
commencé plus tôt
alain bernard est maintenant
public c'est une vague
et en tant que téléspectatrice sans
enfants le vendredi soir peut-être que
je vais faire un dîner je vais pas
regarder koh lanta et le mardi je vais
le regarder justement jusqu'à mâcon
enfants à ça je ne sais pas encore mais
ça pour vous dire que le marché
oui oui vraiment à moi ça y est j'ai
fait des enfants c'est pas le niveau
d'émission tir moi je vais pas mentir
aux gens j'ai toujours dit que koh lanta
jacques rocher pas que cette émission
que je regardais pas je tombe dessus de
temps en temps et je fais même départ
est que mes potes des fois je leur dis
donnez moi même 1500 euros je suis pas
capable de vous sortir cinq mecs de koh
lanta même aujourd'hui donnez moi 1500
euros pour dépression donnez moi cinq
mecs de koh lanta je vais pas vous
laisser sortir même si vous me posez
2000 euros sur la table d'où sortent à
l'oisiveté moins cinq mètres de koh
lanta et vous il ya 5 millions sur la
table non mais la production
non mais sans m'aider il ya claude qu'à
gagner dans ce cas les photos derrière
ces noms mais même avec les photos je le
connais pas je vais vous jure c'est vrai
de vraiment ça mais roger pailles à
claude yaméogo moundir moundir me dire
il a fait koh lanta herriot
non moi cette fois j'adore koh lanta
mais cette saison ne me plaît pas parce
qu'on s'attend vraiment avoir un choc
des guerriers comme ils nous l'ont
annoncé ce sont les vingt ans et là en
l'occurrence ils ont tous peur d'être
trop fort de se faire éliminer donc en
fait ça joue pas ça fait des vieilles
stratégies pourri alors qu'on veut
passer à koh lanta on veut du jeu on
veut de la gaine non je suis pas très
séduite et je ne regarde pas beaucoup
cette année j'avoue alors gilles le
mardi ça ne me plaît pas elle au contenu
est mauvais dans une équipe le mardi ne
changent pas la qualité des missions
roger ce mardi ça me plaît pas
[Applaudissements]
sérieusement nui se passe rien je
m'ennuie en contre de femmes c'était
mauvais d'ailleurs ils ont vite rectifié
ils ont changé le nom de route donc ça
ne me plaît pas parfois vous adorez koh
lanta et d'une saison à l'autre bout de
mes plus beaux soient pourquoi quelle
mouche vous piquent cette saison là je
la mets test très bien voilà moi c'est
tranché oui madame
je n'aime pas non plus le mardi il faut
toujours une demi-heure alors je sais le
programme pour me souvenir qu'à ça sur
tf1 en revanche je vous trouve très dur
parce que les épreuves elles aussi sont
durs et que honnêtement eu peut-être
qu'ils jouaient la prudence mais
honnêtement ça se laisse regarder et
c'est que c'est costaud physiquement
contrairement à ce que vous dites donc
oui moi je pense que le programme n'a
pas d'usure oui c'est un programme que
j'affectionne moi je suis fan de koh
lanta je regarde depuis des années cette
année je regrette que pas mon chouchou
parce que moi mon super héros c'était
grégoire
jaguar et il était bourré voir le toi +
moi
c'est une évocation non non non
dylan on ne te connais bien je crois
qu'il s'est pas bob
et puis pour des gens c'est super pour
voyager ne serait ce que pour sa part
allé voir le monde sa la dispense
astique on découvre des paysages
incroyables on sent que la même chose
une fois les jo c'est l'une
des deux fois que c'est à tahiti
en thèse de fox à tahiti ils vont rester
là bas tout le temps avec le colis comme
c'est considéré comme un territoire
français
territoire français c'est papa et en
polynésie
oui se fie à moi je regardais en fête
avec les enfants quand ils étaient
petits maintenant c'est vrai que koh
lanta ce alors pas cela mais si je tombe
dessus par exemple y lire je voulais
regarder le concert de johnny j'ai
trouvé ça tellement nul que j'ai zappé
sur tf1 donc j'avais dit quoi le concert
de johnny devinez quoi juste après le
premier tour mais ça tellement nul que
j'ai zappé sur tf1 et donc du coup en
fait quand on zappe sur koh lanta
finalement on reste et je trouvais je
suis d'accord avec isa je trouve que le
niveau il est quand même vachement
costauds quoi les mecs qui vont faire le
parcours du combattant
si en plus il connaît
alors vu les belles quoi moi je suis pas
du tout d'accord avec sophie cheveux koh
lanta c'est un regardable si vous n'êtes
pas un fan de l'émission moi là je suis
passé deux saisons je regardais extrait
je ne comprends rien je connais pas les
histoires les règles sont ultra
compliqué elles changeaient à chaque
saison là où quand vous tombez sur
l'amour est dans le pré ou sur fort
boyard en zappant c'est immédiat ça vous
comprenez vous avez un mec qui veut
sortir avec une nana ou l inverse vous
comprenez qu'on parle là on vous parle
d'histoire d'il ya deux semaines de
stratégie de mécanismes pour
longtemps du combat je vais tomber mais
je ne comprends pas que l'on tape alors
que le concept de bâle est super
contre les rouges à la bassée